hey guys what's up this is andrew for
trainsenses.com so in this video guys
i'm here to make a midweek update i mean
end of week update on gme yes before the
weekend because we have a nice situation
so i want to discuss what can happen
here let's get into it
[Music]
all right guys so uh as you know i
usually do my amc and jimmy videos
during the weekend i will start to make
it more during the week now i have more
time because i have finished to
finally do my course guys by the way
it's still 50 discount until the end of
this week only and i can't repeat that
enough guys it's gonna help you you
don't even imagine how much and i'm
gonna show you here a little example of
how to use what i have in this course uh
yeah and what i wanted to say now i have
more time more time guys so i can do you
know pretty much everything you guys
want me to do so jamie amc i know you
guys love that i will keep doing it but
i will also try to do more different
stocks see if you guys like it i'm here
to do what you want me to do all right
so here jamie i know this one you're
gonna love it i have already discussed
that quickly in my last gme video guys
we are having a build up all right so
let me for those who haven't watched
that video let me quickly show you again
so first i'm going to explain what is
the buildup and what consequences it
usually has so build up is an area it's
a consolidation where the price action
is moving on low volume
with low volatility the volatility is
the amplitude of the moves which means
we make small moves on low volume look
at the volume guys
dropping okay
and look at the moves it's converging
inside this triangle right so this is a
build up the last time we had one is
here okay same thing look at the volume
dropping converging inside the triangle
then here we had a downside breakout and
then we moved lower so here let's see if
it's an upside breakout or downside
breakout but the breakout will happen
guys before
the end of the triangle it usually
happens around this area
you see here it happens whenever you
draw your triangle it doesn't happen
very often that we go to the very bottom
of it all right you will usually have a
breakout at the two thirds like 60 70
percent of the length of the triangle
i'm going to show you more triangles so
here it's coming soon guys so maybe
today maybe tomorrow
i mean monday maybe tuesday but it's
going to happen in the coming days
i'm going to discuss what's going to
happen in which situation but first i
want to show you a little bit
more situations like this because it
happens on every time frame guys
here
bam so i was on a regular scale guys
because it's more adapted for short term
now i'm gonna look but i'm gonna be
looking for long term so long term it's
better to use logarithmic scale guys
same thing i explained that very well in
my course explain everything that
basically you guys need to learn so that
you are able to understand price action
dynamics and how to
uh properly anticipate market turning
points all right so this is what we're
having right now the market is gonna
shift
soon take a direction and follow it
probably
so uh here look massive triangle guys
okay
here bam
and same thing so here we went a bit
further
we went to 85 percent maybe of this
length all right if here it's a zero
here it's the end of the triangle 100 we
went to here and here the market took a
direction on the downside so you never
know if it's going to be on the upside
or the downside but you have some hints
that you can use to anticipate but the
best thing to do is to wait for the
breakout and after the breakout to take
your position so i know that you guys
already have
dmi shares so what you can do if we have
a downside breakouts is maybe to
uh buy puts sell calls
reduce your position i know you don't
like it i'm just suggesting you know
what is possible to do but what is
probably going to happen guys is on the
upside why so of course i'm not sure of
that but i'm just sharing the different
reasons i think it will be on the upside
okay so let me get rid of all that okay
so first
to know
what is gonna be the breakout
direction first you need to identify
what kind of pattern you have here we
have a triangle guys all right so
triangles are continuation patterns
which means that 70 of the time the
breakout will occur in the direction of
the trend okay
as opposed to reversal breakouts okay
and once again i'm explaining all of
that guys in my course so just saying
and here for example you can see we had
a continuation
a triangle
so we had a move in the same direction
as the trend we were coming from the
highs we went to the lows all right it's
a continuation pattern the trend doesn't
shift
the trend goes in the same direction
just after a small pose so here
you need to ask yourself what is the
trend to know that you can look at
different things first you can look at
the macd it's a momentum indicator so
whenever it goes it's going higher it
means that the trend is bullish here
we're getting higher since here here as
you can see the magdie was dropping okay
but i mean here it was going a little
higher but the trend of the macd was
clearly bearish to have a better view of
that you can just zoom out and now you
see the macd here the weekly macd was
heavily dropping right and now it's
flatish okay so first thing the macd is
telling us that the trend is rather
bullish on the short term of course on
the medium term we are bearish guys okay
until 160. but uh which is by the way
the target that i'm going to give you
guys very soon if we have an upside
breakout so here
first thing yeah uh macd macd is going
up on the daily mac media flat is on the
weekly rather bullish information from
the magazine then look at the trend guys
we have a trend here whenever you have a
trend try to look for a good breakout
once again i explained that in my course
and a good breakout is something like
that guys all right volume increase
after low volume after small
consideration that is showing you the
trend that is visible breakout we go
higher okay so this is the signal
that this trend
is complete
so if the bearish trend is complete what
are we doing guys we are bullish right
so
to conclude i have two reasons to say
that we have
a move up
that is just taking a breath okay
and we have a triangle so we are
supposed i mean we are likely to have an
upset breakout once again no guarantee
guys i would say 60 40 something like
that okay
but once we have the breakout if we have
a breakout with a volume increase guys
this is looking very good we're probably
gonna continue do the same kind of move
that we did before you can apply fibs
you can just use a one-to-one relation i
mean all of that is working so
one-to-one relation brings us to 160
okay 164 and if i use the logarithmic
scale once again this is the one to use
here it's coming to this trend line as
well which is the major resistance so if
we have a breakout above this triangle
we might go quickly to the 160 level
this is what i've been saying for quite
some time guys
and you know that in this whole move
down i've i've never called for strong
move up i've always said it's going to
take time and i'm still saying it's
going to take time if we go here
probably going to get rejected guys so
we need still time it's too early to buy
some out of the money calls or stuff
like that guys it's just going to be a
waste of money i think for now we still
need time but on the short term we have
something interesting that's why i do
this end of week video okay guys then we
continue we have more information we
have this stop hunt i've discussed that
once again before guys i'm not going to
go through that again go watch my last
video gme video but basically this is a
bear trap and whenever bear trap happens
usually bears transform in bulls all
right it's like a psychological
phenomenon
that uh just makes you change your mind
whenever you lose money right so when
you whenever you got get caught in a
bear trap if you were a bear you start
to be a buyer all right it's
maybe funny weird but it's happening
like that
in the market so here we have this
information and finally we have here a
bullish engulfing okay so i mean i try
to be objective guys i try to show you
what information i have how i analyze it
and what is my conclusion
and
i only see good
things
and we have
a breakout situation that is coming
so
my very objective point of view is that
we're going to have an upset breakout i
go to 116. maybe maybe i'm wrong i don't
know but this is what i get using my
tools then we have earnings coming here
so amc earnings didn't give us a lot of
move i was expecting maybe the market to
shift it didn't shift so i don't know
what's going to happen with jimmy
earnings but maybe we're going to have
to buy the rumors sell the new situation
okay
you never know how the market is going
to react to news so it's just one
possibility that if we have an upset
breakout the market will be using
earnings as a hope for good information
to be released on the 24th of march
so
this that's it for me once again if you
have a downside breakout that is
confirmed this as you guys can see is
not confirmed we go here but we close
above if we close below 115. guys it's
not looking good probably going back to
87 okay so be prepared for that as well
but it's not the uh
preferred scenario here then guys i'm
not done i have a lot of things to show
you
stay with me stay with me we have
something happening here on the option
market the gamma i'm not going to
explain exactly what is the gamma but
basically it's what makes big move
happen and it's big guys i'm monitoring
that it's quite complicated to explain
exactly how i compute this number but
i'm checking that guys basically the
closer we are to uh the maturity where
you have a lot of options the bigger the
gamma that's why before option expiry we
sometimes have crazy moves and here the
gamma is huge around 120 level all right
so we have one more reason to think that
a big move might happen soon it's three
point four percent usually i see
something a one one or two so we have a
gamma that is two three times bigger
than what we usually have on gme the dtc
does is at po 4.5 guys let me move that
in my records on rgme
uh pam pam pam dtc where is it you see
now we have 4.5 guys it's rebuilding we
were at three
three weeks ago i didn't record it for
three weeks maybe three weeks ago we are
at three
three point five we had four point five
guys it's growing the gamma look three
point four it's the first time i have
such a big game engine
usually two two point
the maximum synthetic shot is still at
22. we have a lot of options on the 950
strike i'm not done guys i'm not done
last thing i wanted to show you the
correlation you guys like to talk about
the negative beta
that is happening with the global market
okay so gme
spy it's coming guys wait a sec
okay look i'm retrieving the data it
always takes some time so what i wanted
to show you guys here is how is the
correlation with the global market so as
you guys know whenever we have a
negative beta we sometimes see crazy
moves so i just wanted to show you guys
that we are not having a negative beta
for now the correlation is here it's on
the upside
it's the blue curve here and you can see
the correlation is around 40 50 okay as
you can see sometimes it goes
dramatically low a very negative
correlation it's a smooth creation a
monthly correction so i'm taking the
returns over one month to make it
smoother
and you can see that and the green curve
is the return so sometimes the return
very high and the correlation is very
negative we've seen that before when
there was quizzes right now the
combination is quite positive
the returns are not amazing but what is
interesting to see this is a monthly
correlation but if i take a weekly
correlation look
five days
instead of 22. what is interesting to
notice so now you don't understand
anything you see here of course because
it's not smooth but look here this is
the correlation and we can see that
during this week we have a correlation
that is close to zero okay 20 30
13 okay it's yellow and before last week
between the 24th of feb
and the 10th of feb it was very positive
so we are slowly the in the last the
past week coming close to a negative
beta situation and i've noticed that on
amc it was more visible but even on gme
so i'm just showing you that because the
global market is tanking a bit today and
i just wanted to show you that these
days the past week there is no big
correlation between what this genie
doing and what is the global market
doing so we can have a global market
going higher gme going higher a global
market going lower gme going higher
everything is possible so just not
correlated that much so let me quickly
conclude i want you to go back here guys
the reason why i make this video is
because we're going to have a breakout
happening soon guys and this breakout
will probably be good quality i can
already see it because we have a volume
dropping and a nice consideration one
more thing you can do is add the
bollinger bands and once again guys i
can't say that enough i'm explaining all
of that in my course you see i'm using
bollinger bands but for a pattern that
is between the tenths of five two weeks
so the daily timeframe is not adapted
you need to switch and here for stem
frame is pretty much adapted once again
i give you a time frame table in my
course guys where i'll show you each
time what time frame you should use okay
so i make it very easy for everyone to
understand and here you need to be on
the first time frame if you want to
check the board in japan and we can see
that they are narrow guys and they are
narrow and i'm pretty sure that we're
going to have a breakout that is going
to be above either the upper band or the
lower band i hope it's going to be on
the upside but if it's on the downside
you need to take it into account as well
guys okay because this is the direction
that the market is probably gonna take
for the coming two three weeks so that's
it for me i hope you guys enjoyed this
video and if you did please don't forget
to click on the sub like and bell button
so you're gonna be the first to know
when i upload anything new and stay
close to shore see you guys